[Musique]
elle est peu que j'ai fait pareil
dernière aucune chaîne de télé ne
voulait plus de moi j'étais complètement
rejetés de partout et je suis allé voir
cl du peloux type qui avait rien à voir
à la télé que c'est fait je crois
l'école des mines qui dirigeait pour le
groupe suez
la chaîne paris première qui à l'époque
n'appartenez pas encore à m6 que tu es
une petite chaîne qui diffusait surtout
dans la journée je suis allé le voir j
écoutais cyril je vous propose un deal
vous ne donnez la fréquence la nuit je
fais une chaîne qui s'appelle paris
dernière et moi je vis de la pub que
vous me rapportez les programmes que je
vais diffusée sur la chaîne la nuit avec
la tde rire médias déjà pas de pub le
jour alors la nuit ça risque pas
d'arriver m'a dit mais si on voulait
faire une émission qui s'appelle paris
dernière faite le et là j'ai eu l'idée
la première émission au monde en caméra
subjective c'est à dire que moi on me
voyait pas sauf quand je passais devant
un miroir mais je voyais tout ils
étaient specter voyez à travers mon
regard la nuit parisienne voilà c'était
le concept
j'ai commencé l'émission 95 je les fait
pendant un an et ensuite c'est frédéric
taddeï qui a pris avec bonheur la
succession et sert duré une dizaine
d'années alors je vais créer une grille
de programmation
parce que dans chaque émission il
fallait qu'ils les mêmes ingrédients y
avait toujours une star un yuko marc un
intello du sexe etc
les rendez vous était pris de neuf
heures du soir à 2 heures du matin il ya
eu une deuxième équipe qui passait avant
nous
or il arrivait chez les gens chez qui on
allait aller y regarder si la lumière
était bien il m'était des micros
planquer et quand moi j'arrivais comme
une fleur bon jour et là on avait
l'impression que c'était magique
évidemment sauf que s'étaient préparés à
partir de là c'est l aventure une espèce
de dérive nocturne incroyable dans
laquelle jambes arquées les
téléspectateurs avec moi les gens
province qui regardaient halluciné ce
qui se passait à paris dans les endroits
un peu louche
alors tout était en caméra à l'épaule
porté par sylvain bergère
tout était en junk ça voulait dire qu'on
cherchait pas à faire un montage en
faisant des raccords
ont coupé net l'image sauter quand
l'interview était chiante on accélérait
l'image on accélérait aussi l'image
cantons traversés paris mais là on met
une musique / s'est accéléré c'était que
des reprises que des cover fêter la
musique de paris dernière 2 béatrice
ardisson
c'est resté célèbre alors qu on sait
tous qu'on voulait en avaient retrouvé
michel legrand sur scène au moment du
baisser de rideau le public sorti de la
salle non rester avec lui et nous jouer
les moulins de mon coeur
on allait visiter un club échangiste
quand les a tous fait des clubs
échangistes on allait interviewer des
des clients en pleine action qui nous
répondait comme ça en film et un castrat
sur le quai devant notre dame qui
chantait une chanson des beatles
on a fait des trucs très beau c'était
pas seulement crapoteuse y avait des
trucs très très beaux légumes hic il y
en avait qu'un minime hic c'est que
quand on voyait un quidam qui promenait
son chien on arrêter la voiture
j'allais le voir ce qu'est ce qu'il est
beau votre chien vraiment mais vous
l'avez eu comment est dix fois sur dix
le mec ne disait pas le congrès c'est
vrai qu'il est bon des bâtards
épouvantable mais évidemment il est très
très bo le chien là et c'était notre kif
saisis m'emmerder mais je t'avais des
chiens alors qu'est ce que je peux vous
recommander dans paris dernière il ya la
fameuse visite de l'usiné de poupée
gonflable avec la musique de kraftwerk
les mannequins qui est assez
exceptionnel
il ya le loft de pablo kalia qui était
directeur artistique du palace qui
vivait dans un loft dans les frigos
d'austerlitz la maison pierre hal gill
qui est un endroit absolument incroyable
dans le kitsch d'un baroque surréaliste
et puis ça peut être aussi un travesti à
pigalle je tombe sur un travesti et j'ai
commencé à lui parler j'y parle de sa
vie ça dure un quart d'heure et à la fin
il a les larmes aux yeux c'est
formidable voilà c'était paris dernière
la seule émission que je referai
volontiers
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
vinardi tube abonnez vous je m'étais un
peu ce bleu